hey this is presh talwalkar
can you find the total area of the red
spots
the diagram involves a rectangle with
dimensions 10 and 20.
the rectangle has one of its diagonals
connected
inside the rectangle are two circles of
equal size which are tangent to each
other and tangent to the rectangle
if you can solve this problem
then try this much harder variation
this was supposedly asked to sixth
graders in china
can you now find the total area of the
red spots
give these problems a try and when
you're ready keep watching the video for
the solution
we'll get started on the first problem
we'll solve for the area of the red
regions by subtraction
we'll take the area of this triangle
and then we'll subtract out
different portions of the circles
so we can set up a formula that the area
of the red regions is equal to the area
of this right triangle
minus
the area of each of these pieces from
the different circles
now it looks like these two pieces
actually join to form one circle
you can notice this by symmetry
and i will illustrate it by putting
these two pieces together
we now solve for the area of each piece
the area of a right triangle is its base
times its height divided by two the area
of a circle is pi times r squared
the right triangle has a base of twenty
and a height of ten
the circle has a radius which is equal
to half the height of the rectangle
and its radius is equal to five
so the circle
has an area of pi times five squared
this means the area of the red regions
is equal to 100 minus 25 pi
or approximately 21.46
now let's tackle the second part of the
problem
we know the area of the red regions as
illustrated is 100 minus 25 pi
the second part says
what would happen if you remove this
region from the lower left hand corner
so we can solve for the red regions by
solving for the area of this particular
piece
to do that we'll consider a simplified
diagram we'll just consider one of the
circles and it'll be inside of a square
with side length 10.
we can again solve this by subtraction
we consider this right triangle
we're going to remove
this portion from the lower right hand
corner and then we're going to remove
this portion of the circle
and what remains is the
area of the lower left hand corner
so we'll set up our formula that the
area we want is equal to the area of the
rep of the triangle
minus the area of this piece in the
lower right hand corner
minus this piece of the circle
the area of the right triangle is its
base times its height divided by two
this right triangle has a height of five
so its area will be ten times five
divided by two
what about the piece in the lower right
hand corner
we can solve this by subtraction
we'll consider one quarter of the square
this square has a side length of five
we then subtract out one quarter of the
circle
so we can solve for this piece by taking
one quarter of the square and
subtracting out one quarter of the
circle
this square has a side length of five so
its area is 25
the circle has a radius of five so one
quarter of the circle is pi times five
squared divided by
four so we solve for this portion as 25
times 1 minus pi over 4.
so we just have one more piece to solve
for
this is the most complicated part
we'll again consider it by subtraction
we'll consider this sector of the circle
we'll then remove out this isosceles
triangle and that'll leave us the area
of the piece we want
so we can again set up a formula that
the region we want is equal to the area
of a sector of the circle
minus the area of this isosceles
triangle
in order to calculate these areas we're
going to have to use formulas for these
particular shapes
if we have a circle with the radius of r
and a sector
having an angle alpha and this is in
radians then the area of the sector is
equal to r squared times alpha divided
by 2.
for a triangle with side lengths a b
and an angle in between them of beta
its area is equal to a times b times the
sine of beta divided by two
so we now need to consider what are the
angles involved and what are the lengths
involved in these formulas
well the circle has a radius which is
one half of the square which has a
length of ten so the radius is five and
the radius is five over here too this is
also the other side of the triangle so
we have an isosceles triangle
if we consider the right triangle from
the lower left hand corner and say this
has an angle of theta
the radius of the circle will be
parallel to the side of the rectangle
so its corresponding angle over here
will also be theta
the other side of this triangle we have
an isosceles triangle so it will also
have an angle theta
this means the central angle of this
sector will be two pi will be pi
minus two theta
because the angles in a triangle add up
to pi radians
so we can now substitute in these
dimensions into our formulas
we can simplify the formula for sine of
pi minus two theta because sine of pi
minus two theta is equal to sine of two
theta
sine of pi minus any angle is equal to
sine of that angle so now we need to
consider what is this angle theta
well in our original triangle it has a
base it has a height of 5 and a base of
10.
so we can use trigonometry to say that
the angle theta is equal to the inverse
tangent of 5 over 10
which is the inverse tangent of one half
so we can substitute that in and we'll
simplify our formula for the area of the
sector
now for the area of the isosceles
triangle we can use the double angle
formula for sine of two theta
and simplify that a bit
and now we need to solve for the sine of
theta and the cosine of theta
well in this right triangle we have one
side length ten and a height of five
so we know that it's diagonal can be
solved by the pythagorean theorem so we
have a ten squared which is a hundred
plus five squared which is twenty-five
so that means
the square root of these is the sum of
these is equal to the length of the
hypotenuse so the hypotenuse is equal to
the square root of 125.
so we can solve for the sine of theta as
5 divided by the square root of 125 and
the cosine of theta is equal to 10
divided by the square root of 125.
so substituting that in and simplifying
we end up with the area of this
isosceles triangle is equal to 10.
and now we have a formula for the region
of the circle that we want it's 25 pi
over 2 minus 25 the inverse tangent of
one half minus 10
so we have all the different areas of
the pieces we want and we can simplify
this formula
to get the area of the lower left-hand
corner is equal to 10 minus 25 pi over 4
plus 25 times the inverse tangent of
one-half
so we'll put this all together
this is approximately 1.956
so now we're going to put this all
together and we're going to calculate
the area of the red regions
so as illustrated the red regions are
100 minus 25 pi
in our second problem we want to remove
this one piece in the lower left hand
corner which we just solved for
so we can substitute that in our formula
and then simplify to get the area of
these red regions is a 90 minus 18.75 pi
minus 25 times the inverse tangent of
one half
and this is approximately 19.504
did you figure this out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description